This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This is our special Halloween episode, so I'm gonna turn up a little bit of this in a little of this. Just to get us in the mood. Oh, and here, here's some moons. Moons are creepy. All right. A couple of weekends ago, the whole 99 P.I. team got together to do something. None of us had done since we were 13 net slumber parties. I feel like we need to like recite something first, right? And it basically sounds exactly like it did
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这是我们的万圣节特别节目，所以我打算把这个调大一点，再把那个调一点。好让我们更有过节的气氛。哦，对了，还有这里，有一些月亮。月亮挺诡异的。好了。几个周末前，整个 99 P.I. 团队聚在一起做了一件事，自从我们 13 岁办睡衣派对以来，我们中谁都没做过。我觉得我们得先背诵点什么，对吧？听起来基本上跟
when we were 13 at slumber parties. Who's there? You're still here. You're out of your hour. That night at my house, we turned out all the lights and lit candles and attempted to summon the spirit world with a Ouija board. That's producer Katie Mingle. She was our host that evening. We were using
我们 13 岁在睡衣派对上时一模一样。谁在那儿？你还在。你超时了。那天晚上在我家里，我们关掉所有灯，点起蜡烛，试图用通灵板召唤精神世界。那是制作人凯蒂·明格尔。她那天晚上是我们的女主人。我们用的是
a homemade board that Avery designed in the style of a store-bought Egypt Board. Two arced rows of letters, the top row A through M, the second row N through Z, and then below the letters, a straight row of all the single digit numbers. And then of course, yes and no in the upper left and right corners, respectively, and goodbye at the bottom of the board. So the way we just supposed to work is participants, usually to, though sometimes more, ask a question to the spirits. And then they, the participants, lightly rest their fingers on a planchette, which is the pointer that slides around the board. And you're not supposed to push the planchette, Sam Greenspan, you're supposed to allow the
埃弗里设计的自制棋盘，风格模仿的是商店买的埃及通灵板。两行成弧形的字母，第一行从 A 到 M，第二行从 N 到 Z，字母下方是一行直排的所有个位数。当然，左上角和右上角分别有“是”和“否”，棋盘底部则是“再见”。所以这个东西本来的运作方式是，参与者通常两人，有时更多，向精灵提问。然后他们，也就是参与者，将手指轻轻搭在指示器上，指示器就是那个在棋盘上滑动的指针。你可不应该推那个指针，萨姆·格林斯潘，你应该让
spirits to guide it around the board, indicating what letters or words they're attempting to communicate. You pee? The Ouija board is so simple and iconic and it looks like it comes from another time. Like it has real history, which it turns out is more than just good design. People have been gathering around a board like this one for about 130 years. Hi, my name is Robert Merch. Most people call me Merch and I'm considered the world's foremost expert on Weeja and talking boards. Merch also collects boards and all sorts of other Weeja related artifacts.
精灵引导它在棋盘上滑动，指出他们试图传达的字母或单词。你尿急吗？通灵板非常简单，极具标志性，看起来像是来自另一个时代。就像它有真正的历史一样，事实证明，这不仅仅是设计得好。人们围绕着这样一块棋盘聚集在一起已经大约 130 年了。嗨，我叫罗伯特·默奇。大多数人叫我默奇，我被认为是世界上首屈一指的维贾图和谈话板专家。默奇还收集棋盘和各种其他与维贾图相关的文物。
So the stuff is everywhere. You know, I frame things. The arrangement I have with my husband is that I can only put things on the wall that can be framed. Now, when he made that agreement, he didn't realize that I could frame anything. So, yeah, that was unfortunate for him. Merch says to understand where talking boards came from. That's the generic term, talking boards. If to go back to the middle of the 1800s, to three sisters in New York.
所以这些东西到处都是。你知道的，我把东西装裱起来。我和丈夫达成的协议是，我只能把能装裱的东西挂在墙上。现在，当他做出那个约定的时候，他并没有意识到我可以装裱任何东西。所以，是的，这对他是挺不幸的。默奇说，要了解谈话板是从哪里来的——这是通史术语，谈话板——必须追溯到 19 世纪中叶，纽约的三个姐妹。
The Fox sisters, they are really what starts this explosion of mediumship and spiritualism in America and beyond. The Fox sisters claim to be mediums to the spirit world, and in public demonstrations, they would ask questions of the spirits and receive audible knocks back on the wall, knocks that they translated into letters of the alphabet. The Fox sisters were a sensation. They were the most visible faces of a growing movement known as spiritualism, which held that spirits of the dead could be contacted by the living
福克斯姐妹，她们确实开启了媒介和精神主义在美国及其他地区的爆炸式发展。福克斯姐妹声称自己是通往精神世界的媒介，在公开演示中，她们会向精灵提问，并收到墙上传回的清晰敲击声，这些敲击声被她们转化为英文字母。福克斯姐妹引起了轰动。她们是一个被称为精神主义的日益壮大的运动中最引人注目的面孔，该运动认为死者的灵可以与生者联系，
and that they had secret knowledge to impart. When tales of the fox sisters swept through American newspapers, more and more people started to believe. During and after the Civil War, spiritualism became even more important to people. Everyone had, you know, whether it was a father, a son, a grandfather, an uncle. You know, they all lost somebody. People just went away and they didn't come back. So, what else are you going to do?
并且他们有秘密知识要传授。当福克斯姐妹的故事席卷美国各大报纸时，越来越多的人开始相信。在内战期间及之后，精神主义对人们变得更加重要。每个人都有，你知道的，无论是父亲、儿子、祖父，还是叔叔。你知道的，他们都失去了某个人。人们就这样离去了，再也没有回来。所以，你还能怎么办呢？
You know, you turn to trying to make contact with these people who are gone. And in 1886, the fledgling associated press ran an article in papers all over the country about these new talking boards coming out of the spiritualist movement in Ohio. It's unclear whether he read the article, but a few years later, in 1890, a businessman named Charles Canard of Baltimore, Maryland realized this talking board could make him lots and lots of money. Canard pulled together a small group of investors and formed the Canard novelty company to exclusively make and market talking boards. Contrary to popular beliefs, the name Ouija is not a combination of the French and German words for yes,
你知道的，你只能转而试图与这些已经离去的人取得联系。1886年，崭露头角的联合通讯社在全国各地的报纸上发表了一篇文章，报道了这些源自俄亥俄州精神主义运动的新型谈话板。目前还不清楚他是否读过那篇文章，但几年后，即 1890 年，马里兰州巴尔的摩市的一位名叫查尔斯·卡纳德的商人意识到，这个谈话板可以为他赚取大量金钱。卡纳德拉拢了一小群投资者，组建了卡纳德新奇公司，专门制造和销售谈话板。与大众的看法相反，“Ouija”这个名字并不是法语和德语中表示“是”的词的组合，
we and yeah. Merch says that according to documents belonging to the original founders of the company, they sat down and asked the board itself what it wanted to be called. And letter by letter it spells out the UIJA. And when they ask the board what that means, O-U-I-J-A. And when they ask the board what that means, the board spells out good luck. They called the board Ouija, the Egyptian luck board. They added Egyptian just for a little exotic flair. The patented Ouija board looked a lot like the talking boards that came out of the spiritualist movement. The only real substantial change was that the Ouija board put the letters of the alphabet in a double arc instead of two straight lines across. There have been a few small design changes
即“we”和“ja”。默奇说，根据属于该公司创始人的文件，他们坐下来问棋盘本身它想被叫什么。然后它逐字拼出了 O-U-I-J-A。当他们问棋盘那是什么意思时，O-U-I-J-A。当他们问棋盘那是什么意思时，棋盘拼出了“好运”。他们把这个棋盘叫做 Ouija，即埃及幸运板。他们加上“埃及”只是为了增加一点异国情调。获得专利的 Ouija 棋盘看起来很像从精神主义运动中走出来的谈话板。唯一实质性的改变是，Ouija 棋盘把英文字母排成了一个双层弧形，而不是横跨棋盘的两条直线。有些许小的设计改变
since the early boards. For example, there was once a full moon and a crescent moon in the top left and right hand corners. Eventually, the full moon became a sun, which is what you see now. But through the years, the brand has always been very identifiable. So the WeChat board has always been very simple. Anyone who looked at it would know, okay, that's a WeChat board.
自早期棋盘以来。例如，左上角和右上角曾经有一个满月和一个弯月。最终，满月变成了太阳，也就是你现在看到的这样。但多年来，这个品牌一直辨识度极高。所以维贾图棋盘一直非常简单。任何看到它的人都会知道，好吧，那是维贾图棋盘。
By 1893, Charles Canard had left the company, and it was taken over by William Fould, who had come to be known as the father of WeChat. Fould's New York Times obituary actually credited him with inventing the board, which of course he did not do, but he was incredibly good at selling it. Instead of being a straight-up evangelist for the boards, he'd purport to be one of the skeptics. You would say, I don't believe in the Wege board.
到 1893 年，查尔斯·卡纳德已经离开了公司，公司由威廉·福尔接管，他后来被称为“维贾图之父”。《纽约时报》对福尔的讣告实际上将发明该棋盘的功劳归功于他，当然他并没有发明它，但他极其擅长销售它。他没有直接成为棋盘的狂热信徒，而是自称是怀疑论者之一。你会说，我不相信维贾图棋盘。
You know, I'm no spiritualist. I'm a pros-butarian. And then at the same time, same interview, he would say, but we lost a shipment of Weechy boards on the train tracks and we asked the board where they were, and it told us and then they went down that track and sure enough they found that the train had derailed and we found all our boards. Whether the board worked and how it worked,
你知道的，我不是什么精神主义者。我是长老会教徒。然后在同一时间，同一场采访中，他说，但是我们在铁轨上丢失了一批维贾图棋盘，我们问棋盘它们在哪里，它告诉了我们，然后我们沿着那条轨道去找，果然发现火车出轨了，我们找到了所有的棋盘。至于棋盘是否有效以及它是如何运作的，
whether it was just a game or a more serious spiritual tool, was something fold kept intentionally mysterious. And this marketing strategy was extremely successful. Hey, everyone had one. People played at home with their families. Ladies played at Tea parties. In fact, one of the boards in Merch's collection doubles as a tea tray. People even played with their little kids, which might seem kind of weird now.
究竟它只是一场游戏还是一个更严肃的精神工具，是福尔刻意保持神秘的事情。而这种营销策略非常成功。嘿，每个人都有一个。人们在家里和家人一起玩。女士们在茶会上玩。事实上，默奇收藏的其中一个棋盘还可以兼作茶盘。人们甚至和他们的小孩一起玩，这在现在看来可能有点奇怪。
Fast forward a couple of decades around 1920, and Weja is still good, clean, family fun. And it turned out, it was also a great thing to do on a date. So you're coming out of Victorian times when men and women are not supposed to be alone together. They're not supposed to be in the dark together. They're not supposed to be in the dark together. They're not supposed to be touching. So the original Ouija board would be placed on your lap. Your knees would be touching.
快进几十年，大约在 1920 年代，维贾图依然是健康、纯粹的家庭娱乐。事实证明，这也是约会时做的一件很棒的事。所以你正从维多利亚时代走出来，当时男女不应该单独待在一起。他们不应该一起待在黑暗中。他们不应该一起待在黑暗中。他们不应该有身体接触。所以最初的 Ouija 棋盘会放在你的膝盖上。你们的膝盖会挨着。
Your fingers would be touching on the point and shed. You know, you would be doing it by candlelight. And you can see really quickly that the directions add in, you know, two people a man and a woman prefer. And if you need proof of what a normal part of Americana the Ouija Board was, look no further than the King of Americana himself, Norman Rockwell.
你们的手指会在指针上接触。你知道的，你们会在烛光下进行。你会很快发现说明书里增加的内容，你知道的，一男一女两个人更喜欢。如果你需要证据来证明维贾图棋盘是美国文化多么正常的一部分，看看美国文化之王诺曼·洛克威尔就知道了。
In 1920, he made a painting of a man and a woman in the position merch just described. Knees touching, he looking flirtatiously at her, a Ouija board resting in their laps. And the first and loudest were actually the people who's jobs these talking boards had just stolen. We see mediums actually saying, these things are dangerous. You don't know what kind of doors you're opening.
1920 年，他画了一幅画，画中一男一女正处于默奇刚刚描述的姿势。膝盖相碰，他调情地看着她，一个 Ouija 棋盘放在他们的膝盖上。而第一批也是声音最大的人，其实正是那些工作刚被这些谈话板抢走的人。我们看到通灵者实际上在说，这些东西很危险。你根本不知道你打开的是什么门。
You need someone like me who's experienced to guide you through this unseen world. Now why would they say that? Well because it's cutting into their profession, their money. But Nasey was stayed on the fringe through the years. Oh sure, there'd be the occasional the Ouija board told me to do it murder that would make it into the news. But they were a few and far between. Throughout the decades, Ouija mostly held on to its wholesome reputation.
你需要像我这样有经验的人来引导你穿过这个看不见的世界。现在他们为什么这么说呢？好吧，因为这切断了他们的职业，动了他们的奶酪。但多年来，邪恶一直处于边缘地位。哦，当然，偶尔会有“维贾图棋盘让我这么做”的谋杀案登上新闻。但它们并不常见。几十年来，维贾图主要保持了其健康的声誉。
Until... Mother of the Year! Mother of the Year! Mother of the Year! Mother of the Year! Mother of the Year! Mother of the Year! Mother of the Year! Mother of the Year! Until The exorcist released in 1973 I had to sleep in my parents bedroom for a week after I saw this when I was a kid At the beginning of the movie the main character's mother discovers she's been playing with a Ouija board. The exorcist is really the first big media moment that infers that playing a Ouija board
直到……年度母亲！年度母亲！年度母亲！年度母亲！年度母亲！年度母亲！年度母亲！年度母亲！直到 1973 年《驱魔人》上映我小时候看完这个在我父母卧室睡了一个星期电影刚开始时，主角的母亲发现她一直在玩维贾图棋盘。《驱魔人》确实是第一个暗示玩维贾图棋盘
by yourself, could lead to demonic possession. The following years saw the Ouija board denounced by religious groups as Satan's preferred method of communication. Ouija board denounced by religious groups as Satan's preferred method of communication. Ouija boards aren't harmless. Sayonses aren't harmless. Listen, don't be playing games on Halloween. Don't call on demons because they'll come and live with you. The Bible says he who seeks evil, evil will come to him. Pat Robertson is pretty extreme, but still still the image of the board changed a lot since that Norman Rockwell painting in 1920. Parker Brothers and later Hasbro, which acquired Parker Brothers in 1991, still sells a lot of
独自一人可能会导致恶魔附身的重大媒体事件。随后的几年里，维贾图棋盘被宗教团体谴责为撒旦首选的交流方式。维贾图棋盘被宗教团体谴责为撒旦首选的交流方式。维贾图棋盘并非无害。通灵会并非无害。听着，万圣节不要玩游戏。不要召唤恶魔，因为它们会来和你一起生活。圣经说，寻找邪恶的人，邪恶就会降临到他身上。帕特·罗伯逊相当极端，但尽管如此，自从 1920 年那幅诺曼·洛克威尔的画以来，棋盘的形象已经改变了很多。帕克兄弟以及后来在 1991 年收购了帕克兄弟的孩之宝，仍然在销售大量
boards, but the reason people buy them has changed. It's not good clean family fun anymore. Now people buy them because they want to get scared. There's another Ouija movie just released called Weja, which will do nothing to change the board sinister reputation. But as sinister reputation is fine with Hasbro. In fact, they put up a lot of the money for that new Weijah movie. They've also released a new version of the game
棋盘，但人们购买它们的原因已经改变了。这不再是健康纯粹的家庭娱乐了。现在人们购买它们是因为他们想体验惊吓。刚刚又上映了一部名为《维贾》的维贾图电影，这对于改变棋盘邪恶的声誉毫无用处。但邪恶的声誉对孩之宝来说没问题。事实上，他们为那部新的维贾电影资助了很多资金。他们还发布了游戏的新版本，
and changed the tagline, which used to be. It's just a game, isn't it? The new tagline? You not play the Weijih board if you think it's just a game. The design of the new board is different too. For the first time in a very long time, the Ouija board got a makeover. They've added a couple of modern features, like a purple light in the planchette, but overall, they've tried to make the board look older than the classic board.
并更改了标语，以前的标语是：这只是一个游戏，不是吗？新的标语是：如果你认为这只是一个游戏，就不要玩维贾图棋盘。新棋盘的设计也有所不同。很长一段时间以来，Ouija 棋盘首次迎来了一次大改版。他们添加了一些现代功能，比如指示器中的紫光，但总体而言，他们试图让棋盘看起来比经典棋盘更古老。
It's brown and kind of weathered, and it looks like something you might find on a pirate ship. They've really gone for the older look, which is neat, because again, people assume these boards have been around for thousands of years, which we know isn't true, but belief is important to the Ouija board. Belief is very important to the Ouija board, especially subconscious beliefs, which brings us finally to how these things work. which brings us finally to how these things work.
它是棕色的，有点风化，看起来就像你在海盗船上可能找到的东西。他们确实追求了更古老的外观，这很整洁，因为同样地，人们假设这些棋盘已经存在了数千年，我们知道这不是真的，但信念对维贾图棋盘很重要。信念对维贾图棋盘非常重要，尤其是潜意识信念，这最终让我们回到了这些东西是如何运作的。这最终让我们回到了这些东西是如何运作的。
Basically, when it comes to the Ouija board, the reason that it seems to work, it feels as if it works, is down to something called the idiomotary effect. And what that is essentially is non-conscious muscular movements. That's Professor Chris French. I am head of the anomalousist psychology research unit at Goldsmiths University of London. And before you ask a anomalousist psychology, is the psychology of weird stuff. The term idiomotor of fact was first coined by an English physician and researcher
基本上，当谈到 Ouija 棋盘时，它之所以似乎起作用、感觉起作用，归结为一种叫做“动念效应”的现象。本质上，这就是无意识的肌肉运动。那是克里斯·弗伦奇教授。我是伦敦大学金匠学院异常心理学研究单位的负责人。在你开口问之前，异常心理学就是研究诡异之事的心理学。动念效应这个词最初是由英国医师兼研究员
named William Benjamin Carpenter back in 1852, right when spiritualism was starting to become popular both in Europe and the US. So the idiomotor effect applies in the case of Ouija in that our bodies are making small subconscious movements that are guided by a suggestion or some subconscious knowledge. And so particularly once the first letter or two has been made apparent, then you kind of get an idea of what's going to come next. So if it was spelling out a name and it's spelled out the letter B and then an O, you might well within the nose because it's probably going to be Bob. And the idiomotor effect becomes magnified as more people play.
威廉·本杰明·卡彭特在 1852 年创造的，当时精神主义刚开始在欧洲和美国流行起来。因此，动念效应在 Ouija 的情况下适用，因为我们的身体正在做出由暗示或某种潜意识知识引导的微小潜意识运动。因此，特别是当出现第一个或前两个字母变得明显之后，你大概就能猜到接下来会发生什么。所以如果它在拼一个名字，而且拼出了字母 B 然后是 O，你很可能会心照不宣，因为那很可能是 Bob。随着更多人的加入，动念效应会被放大。
One of the very interesting things that happens when you talk to people who have played around with Ouija boards is that they will very often claim that they've got answers from the Ouija board that nobody around the board actually knew that. So that proves that it was some kind of external agency. Professor French says that what's happening here is that our subconscious mind does actually know the answer. Our conscious mind just can't access the information. And researchers are so convinced of this. They've even used Ouija boards to study our subconscious.
当你与玩过 Ouija 棋盘的人交谈时，发生的一件非常有趣的事情是，他们经常声称他们从 Ouija 棋盘那里得到了周围任何人实际上都不知道的答案。这证明了某种外部力量的存在。弗伦奇教授说，这里发生的事情是，我们的潜意识确实知道答案。只是我们的意识无法获取这些信息。研究人员对此坚信不疑。他们甚至用 Ouija 棋盘来研究我们的潜意识。
So for example, in one of these studies, participants were asked simple, fact-based questions. Like, it's Buenos Aires, the capital of Brazil. They got the answers right about 50% of the time, but when they used a Ouija board to help them answer the same questions, they actually got higher scores then. They got the answers right about 65% of the time. So in other words, they did know the answer even if they couldn't consciously access it. There have been all kinds of studies done on paranormal experiences and Professor French
所以例如，在一项这样的研究中，参与者被问到简单的事实性问题。比如，布宜诺斯艾利斯是巴西的首都吗？他们大约有 50% 的时间答对，但当他们使用 Ouija 棋盘来帮助回答相同的问题时，他们的得分实际上更高了。他们大约有 65% 的时间答对。换句话说，即使他们无法有意识地获取答案，他们确实知道答案。人们对超自然体验进行了各种各样的研究，弗伦奇教授
says they never reveal an external or spiritual force at work. They always reveal an internal force at work, even if it's a subconscious one. I don't have any doubts in my mind that we can explain the vast majority of ostensibly paranormal experiences by looking to psychology. Whether or not we can explain every single one is the $64,000 question. Wasn't it over? Was it an F1? Yeah, F1. Was it an R?
说它们从未揭示有外部或精神力量在起作用。它们总是揭示有内部力量在起作用，即使那是潜意识的力量。我心中没有任何怀疑，我们可以通过心理学来解释绝大多数表面上的超自然体验。我们能否解释每一个超自然现象，这是一个价值六万四千美元的问题。刚才不是结束了吗？是 F1 吗？对，F1。是个 R 吗？
Yeah. When we played Ouija at my house, the planchette seemed less to be governed by the idiomoder effect and more by the law of inertia. What's going on? Nothing. Essentially, it's not moving. And our experience wasn't terribly strange or creepy.
对。当我们在我家玩 Ouija 时，指示器似乎较少受动念效应支配，而更多地受惯性定律支配。怎么了？没什么。本质上，它根本没动。我们的体验也谈不上多么奇怪或诡异。
It was mostly just slow. Just kind of was, look, it moved a little bit. strange or creepy. It was mostly just slow. But merch has played enough times to have had some weird experiences. Some I think are just the person's pushing it and they don't know it. It's clearly itter your motor response. Other times it's answered things that just seem so bizarre that how would it know. You know, if you can talk to the spirit world, why wouldn't the Ouija board work? And the real question is, can you make contact with the spirit world? And that's a question that has been dugging humanity since the beginning of time, since the first time someone realized when they died, it didn't come back.
主要就是慢。只是有点像，看，它动了一点点。奇怪或诡异。主要就是慢。但默奇玩过足够多次，有过一些诡异的体验。有些我认为只是有人在推它，而他们自己不知道。这显然是你的动念反应。其他时候，它回答的事情看起来如此离奇，它怎么可能知道呢。你知道的，如果你能与精神世界对话，维贾图棋盘为什么不工作呢？真正的问题是，你能与精神世界取得联系吗？这是一个自古以来就一直困扰着人类的问题，自从人们第一次意识到人死后不会复活开始。
After everyone left my house that night, I was sitting on my couch by myself. It was really quiet. I hadn't blown out all the candles yet, so there was kind of a mood. And then one of my spring-loaded blinds slammed up and scared the sh** out of me. And I have to admit, I looked at the Ouija board, and I wondered, just for a second. It's just a game, isn't it? I have got to say hello to an old friend. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Katie Mangle with Sam Green span Avery Trouffleman and me Roman Mars. It was reported by Linda Rodriguez Migrabi and adapted from a piece she wrote for the Smithsonian magazine.
那天晚上所有人离开我家后，我一个人坐在沙发上。四周非常安静。我还没吹灭所有的蜡烛，所以气氛还是有的。然后我的一扇弹簧百叶窗“砰”地一声弹了上去，把我吓了个半死。我必须承认，我看着 Ouija 棋盘，心里纳闷了一秒钟。这只是一个游戏，不是吗？我得跟一个老朋友打个招呼了。本周的 99% Invisible 由凯蒂·明格尔制作，萨姆·格林斯潘、埃弗里·特鲁夫曼和罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。报道来自琳达·罗德里格斯·米格拉比，改编自她为《史密森尼》杂志撰写的一篇文章。
We are a project of many 1.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced of the offices of Arxon, an architecture and interior design firm located in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, all of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links, and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible. You must go to 99i.org.
我们是加利福尼亚州旧金山当地公共广播电台 KALW 的一个项目，办公室位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的一家建筑和室内设计公司 Arxon。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目，我们都在 Twitter、Instagram 和 Spotify 上，但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括酷炫的图片和链接，并收听 99% Invisible 的所有节目，你必须访问 99i.org。
Radio Tapio. From PRX. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX 的 Radio Tapio。来自 PRX 的 Radio Tapio。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。